what can I help you with Lord of
Darkness I'm looking for a date the date
is Friday July 13th no no I want to meet
someone understood you want to eat dim
sum don't you get it I want to go on a
date I'm lonely I understand you want
Bologna though many eyes though few eyes
not into tentacles dad you're stressed
out from working too hard you need a
vacation from running everyone else's
vacation and I know just how to fix it
are we go come on there's so much to do
you could go scuba diving try some
exotic food or just enjoy the views
[Music]
okay God thank you maybe you'll find
your own fireworks on the cruise it's
not The Love Boat Frank you must be the
one and only Dracula
hey do BD Shula a GU BD there's
something about an accent that makes a
man sound so intelligent
dupa days shooting a coupie day you were
right great-grandfather van Helsing
monsters are disgusting they have no
idea what's about to happen to them
all going according to plan
[Music]
there is something about that woman I
don't trust the food here is to die for
must have been garlic in the guacamole
that's deadly for you hey was that you
[Music]
no blog is gonna puke